-Are you aware of the comparison
that people are making between
you and Noah Centineo?
[ Laughter ]
Have you heard -- You ever
heard -- You know Noah?
This is Noah Centineo
right here.
People say you guys look alike.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I wish I was that good-looking.
-No. You are that good-looking.
-No.
-Yeah, you are.
-And they're saying -- They're
saying that you actually --
-He might be able
to play my dad one day.
-He'll play your dad?
-Yeah. Perfect.
We have a clip.
People say that you guys
even sound alike.
-Come on.
-Have you not heard this?
-I've heard --
People have said that, but I --
-Just listen. Here. Check this.
This is Noah Centineo.
-I'm Noah Centineo.
You might know me from "To All
the Boys I've Loved Before"
or "Sierra Burgess" on Netflix.
"Anyone else thinking
that Noah Centineo
could have been a young
Mark Ruffalo? Just me?"
It's not just you.
Casting directors always
comparing me to him.
I even think I am Mark Ruffalo,
and space and time
is just a weird thing
that we can't understand.
-Wow! Is that possible?
-Wow.
-Could that be possible?
-I -- Yeah. Wow. It's amazing.
He's way better-looking
than I was.
-Really?
-Yeah. Are you kidding me?
-You were good-looking
when you were this --
-No. How old is he?
-He's probably like 15 or so.
-No.
I wish I looked like that.
I swear to God.
-Well, actually,
we went on Instagram.
We found a picture of you.
This is you when you were 15.
I think it's not bad.
I think --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-All right, now.
-Similar. I mean, similar.
Come on.
-Noah -- Noah, you're doing
way better than me, pal.
-[ Laughs ]
-I wished I was you.
-You had it rough as a kid
with these braces, huh?
-Yeah.
-Holy moly.
-Look at that. There's no teeth.
It's just all braces.
-Wow! Those are real.
That's unbelievable.
-That's what it used to be like.
I'd go swimming and sink
to the bottom of the pool.
-[ Laughs ]
I mean, that's major league.
How long did you have them on?
-That's some hardware.
Oh, too long.
-Really?
-Well, I was supposed to
have them on for five years,
and I --
-Wow.
-I took them off a little early.
-You took them off yourself?
-Yeah.
-How?
-With pliers.
-Did you really?
-It was my major act
of rebellion in my youth.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God. Your mom --
-My mom was like,
"What are you doing?!
-"That's more expensive
than the house!
-That's it! I've had it!
I've had it!
-I've had it with you, Mark!"
-You're going to have
crooked teeth your whole life!"
And I was like, "I don't care!"
-"I'm going to be in 'Avengers,'
Mom, one day! You'll see!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm the Hulk!"
-I'm sorry, Mom.
She's watching right now.
-Yeah, it's great.
They turned out pretty great.
Can we talk about
"Avengers: Endgame"?
Because everyone's
excited about it, clearly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know. You got in trouble.
It comes out April 26th.
So this is -- But this is --
The last time you were on,
we talked about it,
and we weren't really --
-Yeah, I got in
a lot of trouble.
-You really did.
-Yeah, I did.
And you thought it was funny.
"Ha-ha-ha."
Next thing I know, Joe Russo
has fired me on Twitter.
The President has created a fad.
Now everyone's being fired
on Twitter.
-Dude, that was --
-That's the one positive thing
that will come out of this
presiden-- I'm sorry.
I'm not supposed to say
stuff like that.
-But Tom Holland,
who plays Spider-Man,
he's was known for --
He spoiled a couple things,
and Marvel got real mad at him.
-I love that guy.
-Are you guys allowed
to do press together, or no?
-I just keep -- I'm going to
put him in front of me.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Just like a human
spoiler shield.
-[ Laughs ]
That's hilarious.
-I asked to be paired with him
during the press,
and -- and -- they -- they --
they rejected that.
-Oh, absolutely. They didn't
even let you guys even --
-No, I was like,
"What about me and Tom H--"
I didn't even get "Holland" out.
I was like,
"What about me and Tom H--"
"No! Absolutely not!"
-Yeah, so now who are you on --
have to do the press with?
-Chris Evans.
-Oh, hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
-How cool is Chris Evans?
-I can just sit there
and be beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
-He's a good -- He's a stud.
-He's amazing. Aw, come on.
-It's Chris Evans. Come on.
-Chris Evans.
-He's perfect. We like him.
-He's amazing at everything.
-Yeah.
And he won't spoil anything.
-No, no, no.
He's tight-lipped.
-Yeah, he's good.
-He's Captain America.
-Yeah, of course.
You're not allowed to do that.
-I'm just Bruce Banner.
-That's -- Yeah, but I mean --
I want to ask you more questions
about the "Avengers"
if you don't mind,
but when we come back. Okay.
More with Mark Ruffalo.